and now let us praise the humble dung
beetle in ancient Egypt what we now know
as the dung beetle they called it a
scarab was worshipped the ancient
Egyptians believed that the Scarab was a
God that rolled the Sun across the sky
and buried at each evening where it
emerged the next morning born anew today
you're much more likely to hear TV
comics joking about dung beetles than
find entire countries worshipping them
this is an outrage
why because dung beetles are outstanding
planetary citizens performing a vital
function dung is produced by animals we
rely on for food like cows without dung
beetles there'd be a lot more done
millions and millions of tonnes mph and
that would mean a few billion more flies
dung beetles like these in Africa put
their heads down their bottoms up and
use their super strong front legs to
roll away this dung helped feel with a
fly problem and recycle the dung for a
positive purpose male and female dung
beetles work together to assemble a
suitable dung ball as the centerpiece of
their new home
one beetle burrows unto the earth to
help the dung ball settle in this
aerates the soil and helps the nutrients
in the dung ball nourish the earth once
the dung ball is settled in the female
lays her eggs in the new burrow when the
eggs hatch they feed on the done and
prepare to begin this valuable renewal
of the earth all over again
dung beetles have been around for 50
million years with 7,000 species
worldwide all united in their love of
and need to possess balls have done one
question about dung beetles for a
further study
are they capable of having fun you know
being frivolous we're not privy to the
thought process of dung beetles however
watch this sequence and decide for
yourself now we all know what fun it is
to go to a theme park and take some wild
ride that makes us feel like work out of
control
is this the dung beetle version of this
same giddy urge no safety harness no
crash helmet
whoa that was wicked cool
the humble dung beetle because of it we
live in a better less smelly world